i want you to show
the new york times piece on the
astrazeneca
oxford vaccine yeah okay
so oh i cannot really show it on the
other screen um
there we go thank you so in any case
what we've got here
is a situation with the vaccines that is
far
more interesting and in which there is
far more for us to discuss
than i believe we realize so we have two
first-past-the-post vaccines of this
very new
type this mrna vaccine
platform which is untested in humans
which has only been around
tested in humans for the last nine or so
months
and then we have a third vaccine so
those are
the the makers of those with which are
the names with which people will be
familiar are pfizer
and moderna right right okay so the fiso
modern vaccines
are separately created mrna vaccines
which is a new vaccine technology
which the advantage of which is they can
actually be
developed in like a weekend apparently
um
whereas traditional vaccines tend to
take a lot longer but you can't but
okay but we have no safety record right
of
their long-term implications we have no
concept of how they interface they're
extremely expensive to deploy because of
the need for
extreme refrigeration etc so
anyway i feel like we shouldn't have to
say this every time but because we're
going to get clipped again and again
being called anti-vaxxers and all of
this garbage
let us hope that these mrna vaccines are
what they promise to be this is an
entirely new mechanism
for delivering vaccines and it is quite
possible
that these will be lower side effect
better
and because they're rapidly deployable
this may be the answer to
some of humanity's greatest new problems
which involve emerging new viruses
either
bioterrorism or who knows what else
copen19 won't be the last if mrna
vaccines are effective and safe
that could be the way that we survive
the emerging viruses and even
perhaps viral bioweapons that could be
emerging right
so you and i are rooting for these
vaccines that would be an awesome
addition to our uh antivirus quiver
really hope so
right on the other hand frightening that
we are going to deploy these
at such large scale with some of the
most important people in society in the
midst of a pandemic
without properly investigating
or properly considering what it means to
deploy something on which we have no
long-term data on the safety we don't
know if these cause something
you know months or years years down the
road
so actually let me say that if if these
mrna vaccines
uh five years down the road do um
do prove to have been safe safe-ish
relatively safe you know there will
always be some some problems right if
they do
relatively harmless okay relatively
harmless and
a new virus emerges and a
mrna vaccine is produced very quickly to
deal with that virus
we would not sound the same way about
that mrna vaccine as we do about this
one
now there are still concerns with any
brand new vaccine that doesn't have
a a long period of safety testing but
just
as i believe where you're going to go
here with regard to the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine is that that is a
traditional vaccine is that right yes
and
without knowing anything more than that
about it
i prefer that one simply because the
traditional
way that we have been developing
vaccines has
problems for sure but we have
decades we have many many decades of
safety testing and efficacy testing and
all of this
on this route by which to end up with
vaccines
you and i are more vaccinated than just
about anyone else we know because of the
time we've spent in the tropics all of
this
and that like yes at the moment because
we don't have
the the history on mrna vaccines
we are concerned about what we don't
know
but if it is a class of vaccines that
has five or ten years behind it at that
point every new vaccine that is trotted
out
in that with that technology will
will cause less concern it should cause
less concern it should cause less
concern
and so there's a question we now have a
third vaccine emerging slightly later
it has what should be several things
about it that should cause us to
strongly prefer it
one is it's a normal vaccine that
doesn't require extreme
refrigeration so it's easily deployed
it's
comparatively cheap and astrazeneca
who has teamed up with oxford to
generate this thing has agreed
to have it be profitless
for i don't know what the period is but
for an extended period of time
so they've offered it uh into the the
public space
i think it's i think it's three bucks a
dose or something like that it's very
inexpensive
um we have the emails oh yeah it's like
250 a dose
uh if if deployed by the government ten
dollars a dose
if if privately acquired something like
that right
now very interesting fact about it
so you will hear reported everywhere
that it's much
less effective at preventing covid now
this makes an error in two ways
one we don't really know what the
mrna vaccines um are doing in fact there
is
caution in some circles about the fact
that it may be that people who have been
vaccinated
with these mrna vaccines are still
perfectly capable of transmitting
cloven to other people they just don't
show symptoms is the idea or they
they never show up as having tested
positive somehow somehow
so i i don't expect it will i expect we
will find that it does prevent the
disease and right people
don't therefore transmit but we don't
have but we don't have the data it's all
too
new yeah but in this case you will see
well okay those mrna vaccines are 90
or more percent effective um
astrazeneca's unfortunately
is only uh 60 some percent effective
but get this well but actually the
second sentence here
says a clinical trial revealed the
vaccine was up to 90 effective you know
why
why they made an error in the test did
those who were doing the testing okay
okay in
in this welcome to complex systems folks
they made an error in which they
accidentally have
the dose right so they ran an experiment
they didn't mean to run
and they now have data comparing what
they thought was the full dose
which has something like 60
effectiveness and half the dose which
has
90 effectiveness very much like these
mrna vaccines right
so okay a why does that happen an
inadvertent experiment
that also runs exactly counter to what
you would expect and makes you wonder
how is it
that the people who developed a vaccine
decide on the dosage in the first place
well right and doesn't it just say that
what we ought to be doing one of the
things we ought to be doing is figuring
you know whatever the mechanism is that
we figure out what a dose is and whether
or not you need two of them we need to
vary a lot of stuff in order to figure
out did we miss it because we
you know we're 10 times over the magic
number
right right um you know and in lots of
cases we've we've seen stuff like that
um so anyway the point is okay
so it turns out that the most effective
dose is probably half
what we thought or maybe it gets even
better if you cut it below that who
knows
yeah right wouldn't that be good news um
right so why does it happen we don't
know i sort of have a guess
which is if you think about it so is it
is this also a two-dose vaccine like the
mrna vaccine yes so it's a half so the
idea is it was
up effective when it was a half dose to
start and then a full dose for the
second one if if memory serves
yeah i think that's right but so anyway
i was going to take a guess and i was
going to say one of the things that you
and i puzzled over at length on
early live streams was the fact that the
thing that you see in the textbook about
how a virus gets you
doesn't predict the fact that there's
like a threshold dose
that briefly passing through a room in
which some very
coveted sick person has been exhaling
probably doesn't get you sick but if you
spend a few minutes there it probably
will so there's something
that fills up there's some non-specific
immunity
that gets overwhelmed and at the point
that it gets overwhelmed a virus does
what's in the textbook it invades your
cell
and starts replicating right but until
then
the non-specific stuff is probably good
enough at clearing the garbage without
recognizing it so your prediction here
is that at the higher dose it's actually
making people sick
right that it's basically so what this
is what does vaccine sell
and you can put the that's totally
consistent with other vaccines
right it's you need you need to trigger
your immune system to recognize and
develop the right response
without triggering it so much that you
get full-blown whatever it is the
diseases
you won't get full-blown you won't get
the disease from the vaccine no matter
what
but the test was if you get the vaccine
right are you vulnerable if you
encounter somebody with cove so scroll
up if you can sorry i did not mean to
imply no that's okay
keep going
keep going all right so here
you've got this um adenovirus
vaccine this is the astrazeneca
oxford vaccine it enters the cell and it
does a much more standard thing
than the mrna vaccines the mrna vaccines
bypass the nucleus and what they do is
they dump
mrna into the system which ribosomes
then transcribe
into proteins that then get displayed to
the immune system
in this case you have this virus this
harmless virus
introduce dna with the proper
information in it into the nucleus in a
standard way
the nucleus then transcribes it into
mrna which then
does effectively the same thing from
there that the mrna vaccines do so keep
scrolling up so let me just say that the
only
reason that this feels less science
fictiony than the mrna vaccines
is because we've been doing this for
decades already it is inherently moved
from the realm of science fiction to
science fact
decades ago and the mrna vaccines moved
from science fiction to science fact
in 2020 and therefore we don't know what
all is downstream
yep um so anyway the hypothesis that we
are playing with here
which again this is not our area of
expertise but just based on everything
that we've talked about with respect to
threshold doses and the like
the possibility of the reason that a
higher dose gained
lower effectiveness is that there's some
fraction of the immune system
that is capable of recognizing particles
that look something like the spike
protein
of sars cov2 and if you gum them up
uh with um these viral particles with
these uh
vaccine particles these
vaccine-generated particles that it may
paradoxically open up the chance that a
covid particle that you encounter in the
wild can get by
because they're all gummed up so anyway
that's a different mechanism it's a
hypothesis okay um so anyway it's a
testable hypothesis which is what we
like
um and uh you know so
that predicts things about uh the
curve that you would see for various
dosages um
yeah right that effectively higher would
give you
lower effectiveness at some point
because it would effectively gum up all
the works but
okay so back to the point here we got
three vaccines
two of them are in a totally novel
platform
and therefore carry what you and i have
described as
high risk which does not mean high harm
it means we don't know what happens long
term when you've had this and things
on the list probably uh
include things like um autoimmune
disorders
that will give you an autoimmune
disorder no idea hopefully not by
risking because high uncertainty because
high uncertainty exactly
and we have seen a bunch of stuff in the
article that we covered a couple of live
streams ago
about the um very
poor reporting on the side effects of
the mrna vaccines ought to loom large
here too
people are getting very serious
reactions sometimes to these things
but anyway in a universe where you've
got three vaccines two of which are of
this
very extraordinary new type that come
with high
risk because high uncertainty one of
which is on
a familiar platform it's still
new but we know a lot about it because a
lot of it isn't new right the basic
virus that delivers the thing isn't new
and so this is the one i want right
and it is being portrayed as much less
effective
even if it was 60 effective i think i
still prefer this one
you know and why is that is astrazeneca
not an american company like
what british well actually i don't want
to say it's british i think it is but
oxford certainly
right uh is a british institution yeah
and uh you know we just
we put oh the u.s we put
so much of our funding to um vaccine
development
and not to treatment not to these other
other drugs and also you know it won't
be
if we're right that astrazeneca having
signed up with oxford indicates that
it's not an american company
much of those uh the return on
investment
uh would be far lower for the in-house
in american house developed vaccines if
people start preferring the
traditionally developed
vaccine that came from outside of the
country at the very least we ought to be
discussing
you know the cost of a dose is very
different
the architecture you need to deliver the
dose
is very different rural areas already
exists here we ought to be discussing
okay we're going to give it to all uh
of the medical personnel right makes
sense to protect medical personnel
can we give a quarter of them or half of
them
this is the other one in case there's
something we don't know
i mean that obviously makes sense right
so
the point is you've got any any
demographic
population any demographically described
population
should get a mixture if we are going to
continue to learn
not any combination but some people in
that demographic should get one of these
types of vaccines and some should get
the other and then those results should
be tracked
so the disturbing conclusion i think
from the last little thing where we
talked about the
uh comparison between two drugs where
the world seems to have concluded the
opposite of what would make sense yeah
the comparison here between these
vaccine technologies
um the nonsensical discussion
early on about face masks the
nonsensical discussion we are now having
about face masks where
outdoors people are still uh looking at
each other as morally deficient for
not wearing them i got into a thing on
that this week
i won't go there now the discussion that
we are having
about lockdown and the inability
seemingly of
anybody in charge of policy to juggle
the various
costs of lockdown versus not lockdown
all of these discussions are
as far as i can tell complete garbage
one afternoon with five smart people
and decent information would cause a
radically different
policy decision yep then we are being
fed so what we've got
is just some narrative generated some
way now either
it's generated through incompetence
or it is corrupt which i think is more
likely where
at every little stage of the project i
think we're lucky enough to have both
yeah well undoubtedly the uh
incompetence is a feature not a bug from
the point of view of the corrupters
yeah but it is amazing i think
how far we are likely underperforming
by virtue of the fact that on you know
that what drug you're gonna take
and when you're gonna take it has
apparently been politicized right can
you think of something that could
possibly be a less political question
right um so i don't know what we're
going to do about this
but the whole narrative surrounding
kobit which should unite us
we should have our very best people
coming up with the very
highest quality insights they would no
doubt make mistakes and they should be
pushed back against them
and no amount of pushback should be read
as a political maneuver
right that their work shouldn't be
political or politicized
and the criticisms and uh trying to
figure out if they're actually saying
what they think they're saying and all
of that
shouldn't be read as political either
right this is this is what science is
supposed to do
and we should be discussing this on
twitter and
youtube and every other place without
fear of being thrown off the platform
for having
violated these sacred conclusions or
being placed into your tribal
affiliation on the basis of whether or
not you
are wearing a mask when you're outside
or are questioning whether or not to
take the new vaccine
or are 100 gonna take it no matter what
and you're willing to call people
dummies if they don't
yeah you know none of this is smart
any any of those responses is
you know at at best dim and at worst as
you said
corrupt and corrupting yeah so just
think about how
different the prescription looks if you
just sort of
look at these analyses you know these
analyses could be wrong maybe we've seen
the wrong stuff and there's more
compelling stuff elsewhere but if this
stuff is right
then the answer is don't close your
state parks and other stuff encourage
people to spend as much time outdoors as
possible because among other things
vitamin d and they won't lose their
minds okay
so that's good vitamin d won't lose your
mind those are two protective things
um if you get sick with covid uh
you probably uh want ivermectin and you
want it right away rather than waiting
to see if you get super sick
um and from the point of view of
vaccinating people we've got
some new technologies which are
promising we've got a tried and true one
which is
also rapidly developed incredibly
impressive there
and may be equally as effective much
cheaper
right so uh at least some of us are
easier to deploy
easier to deploy some of us ought to be
getting that one instead and maybe
the fact is we should be trying to get
that to as many people as possible
because it's a better bet
right um so that's a you know that's
like
not radical except in an environment
where we are told that that's all heresy
right because if you take that approach
you can't get looked at and immediately
been put in to be put in a box
and be be labeled and be dismissed
or embraced on the basis of what it is
that you concluded
it is it is actually responsive
to what the research says and i want
like you and i have talked
extensively on here in the past about
why we don't like to say you know
what the data say right like it's not
it's not about data driven it's about
having a model of the universe and
testing that model over and over and
over and over again
and whichever parts of that model
keep on persisting keep on not being
falsified as you test your assumptions
and your ideas and your predictions over
and over and over again
they the longer they persist the greater
the chance is that what you've got there
is a bit of the truth a bit of reality
that is actually reflective of this
objective universe that we live in
regardless of what anyone else says
about it yeah yes
the uh let's put it this way the level
of our failure does not
appear to be closely connected to the
difficulty of the problem
it's a difficult problem but it's
amazing what people have put together
and then
somehow we are going to ignore or
demonize or whatever out of existence
who knows what cost
you